[Music]
have any of you guys
seen that new netflix movie by adam
sandler called
poopy halloween halloween yup was it
good i did watch it
my honest review is that movie sucks ass
huge adam sandler fan so even though it
sucks
i still love the [ __ ] out of it but it's
not one of his best
but i still loved it wait what's the
title who'll be halloween
halloween you know that as a hooby
what is it about is he supposed to be
stupid yes um
well he plays this like stupid guy in
this so what i like about it it's kind
of has a stranger things vibe
where it's like it's not about like a
big world happening event it's very
focused on the small town where everyone
knows each other like the teachers know
the sheriff knows the parents whatever
and then he was like the kid that grew
up in this town and he was like the dumb
guy and it wasn't the jock
but then he had like the best heart and
then so he wins pretty much at the end
by having the best harness
and hello spoiler alert i know what the
spoiler alert he becomes the mayor and
all that that's
awesome why even had to tell us that so
no one needs to watch it because there
it is spoiler so
it's so bad though when you watch it if
i didn't tell you this you probably
won't even finish it wait what about it
oh well the reason why we're talking
about it is because
do you remember during that movie work
with me adam
that movie [ __ ] sucks but i love you
i'm a big fan i love
all those movies feel so good big daddy
are you kidding me big daddy is
everything
yeah i like all these movies are so feel
good i just saw a trailer for one it
came out in 20
uh yeah 2012 and i thought it was a
recent one and it was about him and um
the guy that was his son he was like a
he was like a dad
at 13 he [ __ ] his teacher he popped
out a kid and then he was a dad at 13.
oh with adam
uh with uh andy sam yeah sandberg yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah never heard of
it no i just saw the trailer yesterday i
thought it was a new movie
what was it called something son no no i
just made that up something's not that's
a great title i i don't i don't i didn't
see that one either i think the last
uh adam sandler film i saw was murder
mystery which i didn't hate i liked that
yeah that was good
it was on netflix yeah yeah that one was
good and then the one after that was
good too the one with
uh uncut gems that's not very out of
sight yeah
that's not a very out of sight what am i
saying he's killing it yeah i love the
range
gems is a sick [ __ ] movie you're the
one with chris rock right that one was
good too the wedding one yeah yeah
oh the week up wow okay he's out here
working
okay wait i do want to know why we're
talking about it yeah so
because i was asking you bart do you
remember a scene in the movie when
there's like this newscaster and she's
like
she's doing a news casting
well she's playing um dr quinn yes yes
medicine woman
no no not dr clinton
[Laughter]
i was like why would anyone get the
reference today
who said dr quinn i said yes because
harley quinn is a doctor yeah yeah yeah
okay that's
true anyway
you upset the medicine first thing to
bounce away and our age is showing
she was the first milf i've ever seen oh
it's because we're too young to know the
reference
that's why medicine woman was a show
that used to come on yeah that we turned
off when it came on
yeah i never watched it either yeah like
right around the time of
mash too like i was like [ __ ] these
shows man
it was the lady in wedding crashers the
mom with the that made her
made him feel her boobies sure i kind of
remember but yeah
yeah that's her anyway back to this so
that scene
the act so the newscaster woman she she
actually is in real life
a news anchor or was because
uh she recently announced that because
of her participation in that movie
she unknowingly mistakenly violated her
contract by doing so
oh so she ended up saying like she
understood why management had to cut
ties with her after four years of
working at this
the new station yeah so i'm gonna play
that little clip
isn't that like her asian or a lawyer's
fault oh she's pretty
she's really pretty this is not what i
pictured because she's so cute i
pictured like a 75 year old woman
no she's cute so this is the scene from
the movie
here we go you're watching wake up
boston and it's october 31st which is a
special day across the country but most
especially in salem
america's unofficial halloween capital
you're playing with harley quinn too
sure did aaron oh
his wife adam founder's wife
that's it wait which one's the wife uh
the one on the street
on location oh so cool what what was the
whole big deal is it because she's not
supposed to be a news anchor
like on aside from the well that's the
part that we don't know
there's no curse word she didn't do
anything like i think maybe that is the
thing that's the thing with like the
contracts
well does she not get permission that's
interesting not that you need but
sometimes you need like
i think it's just too similar to what
she does in real life maybe or like
because it's like she
can't be a host of two shows i mean you
can't you can right
but that's parody i've seen tons of news
anchors
actually portrayed like how fishman hal
fishman that's the [ __ ] well
maybe the tv station
she works for is a marvel fan you know
what i mean
like this is dc you know we don't mess
with dc
or maybe they just hate adam sandler
right i mean who would do that though
work with me adam
adam tipswell notice how i'm staying
very neutral i love
adam no i adore adam stay neutral happy
madison put out this movie on netflix
called
the wrong missy it's so bad
but then i started to love it right i
had it on in the background as like
this movie's [ __ ] like i watched like
the first one i'm like oh god this is so
bad
and then there's one part i [ __ ]
cracked up and then i've watched it like
three times now
because it's like one of those movies
just for that one part it just crosses
over
in your head you're like this is so bad
i love it now
oh and then they don't like the room but
not even though because now i genuinely
like
like it yeah not even just saying i need
to watch it again because it was very
like
shocking if you will because it's almost
like oh man this is trying so hard to
do a lot of things so you watched it too
i did watch it
so now i'm like [ __ ] i i like it now
no it was interesting it was it wasn't
what i i didn't know what i expected to
be honest but it was very um
wild the wrong missy on that messiah it
feels like he comes out with the movie
every year
or like two every year yeah he has like
a big netflix deal stuff
on netflix and i like the trailer it was
pretty bad
it's like you know what it is too it's
like the whole gross out comedy genre
it feels like it's it's not a thing
anymore like you almost watch it and
you're like oh bro this isn't like 2006
anymore
it's nostalgic it's an acquired taste um
but but i had fun moments i i should
watch it again i should watch it again
you should watch it again because it's
yeah it's almost like
because i love david spade and lauren
lapkus so
yeah yeah a lot of cameos in it too of
course check it out guys always have a
lot of cameras he always does
he works with the same crew too like he
has his like solid group of peoples
mm-hmm i mean listen we would do that
too you know what i mean like uh we do
that
too in life if you know once we yeah not
me i just graduate
me tomorrow who has the biggest clout
you know
yeah that's why i'm doing a movie of
only gamers
really popular youtube gamers yeah tick
talkers and gamers is my next movie
or my first movie because they're your
real friends
no [ __ ] friendship dog clout you
corrected yourself
for my next movie or my first my first
movie actually
the only movie that i haven't done yet
but yeah so like i said we don't know
exactly where she violated her contract
as to why
she would sack her but that's a bummer
wait what city is this in that
she actually she is in boston yeah like
she is a news anchor
in boston maybe the rules there like the
censorship rules
you know because adam sandler movies are
kind of risque sometimes you know
i don't i don't know anything was
hoochie halloween
who be halloween was that was it it's
like your movie tim
halloween yeah i think i did do a skit
called that i don't hate that um what
was it like
dirty no not really i mean all those
movies are kind of like in the beginning
a bunch of like just stupid kind of like
uh
three stooges type jokes but then they
hit you with the heart you know right
and then you're along for the ride now
and then now all the stupid jokes
actually feel so much better because
there's a lot of heart attached to it
you guys have a favorite adam style
movie well speaking of heart
click yes quick [ __ ] the [ __ ] moment
when he had to rewind the dad saying oh
my
he missed out on life skills yeah it's
the journey
[ __ ] i was bawling i don't know if that
makes you realize how
just us as humans we really do live on
autopilot without that oh i mean
because of this guy because of this guy
especially because even before this guy
yeah
yo actually it was last year that i
started to recognize
the world oh [ __ ] what do you mean by
that where you been this entire time
i don't know because sometimes i'll
watch an old skit that we did and i'm
like
oh we did do that didn't we i don't
remember what happened or i watched
some old vlogs and i'm like this didn't
happen what the [ __ ] who's this person
wow
wow cause you've done so much yeah
that's probably what it is
yeah you're losing your marbles yeah no
i mean
i'm saying that my marbles were lost and
now i'm back into reality all right
you're back you found the marbles
that can't happen guys you can't lose
your [ __ ]
all your life and then you come back to
reality and you can be aware when we
talk about like our old upbringings and
stuff it almost seems like
two three four lifetimes ago yeah
[Applause]
it's scary even just like our own lives
like with each other like when we talk
about our memories of like going on
vacations and then we
we we reminisce and i'm like what the
[ __ ] that did happen
because we've seen so much and we've
learned so much you know i mean we're
not the same people
i remember the vacations though they
were fun i can't believe you forgot them
how dare you i know that was really
special where'd y'all go yeah
that's my marbles that's why where'd
y'all go we just go to hawaii every year
we've been to japan together did you go
some cruises no he's not a part of the
game
no he just became a serious regular he
does he just got promoted we do company
trips
vegas yep oh i would love to join the
vegas one that's a little you know less
commitment less serious do you gamble
i dabble in the blackjack
you mean with your bad luck i mean i'm
i'm yeah i just play sometimes
okay but yeah you like vegas
for what reasons um well
actually i just went before pandemic for
some shows that during pandemic it was
awesome
oh [ __ ] recently like a month ago or
something
wait when do we go so you were at the
night clubs and [ __ ] no clubs aren't
open
but no they are tim really full on how
we know vegas clubs are it's like that
we were at the urgent care making out
with all the corona
that's what we were doing no right can
someone confirm this yeah
no the clubs weren't open no vegas is
open i saw a video
well i when i went vegas clubs i swear i
saw someone's
id story so yeah when we went i think
maybe a month ago uh like
you know when you come out of the
elevator sometimes you'll see like the
nightclub
the bouncer would be there but zero
people in line right now they're not
open
oh wait i saw something
point at her we got her dude we [ __ ]
got him
hotels in vegas have opened the
nightclubs and pool parties will remain
closed until further notice
some pools aren't open but pools are
open i look at the hotel and i'm like
you guys are disgusting down there
yeah the jacuzzis aren't open it's
nothing i could have sworn it was all
open but i guess it's not okay fine so
what'd you do in vegas it's a dream dude
i went to go look at houses with this
dude oh
yeah yeah and then uh we went to eat
restaurants are open
buffets in the hotels no the buffets are
closed the restaurants are open
gotcha right right and then gambling is
open but they got plexiglass and [ __ ]
and buffets are kind of scary you know
like 20 people like like
fighting for crab legs when you think
about it like now that we have these new
you know uh knowledge of germs like
buffets are pretty gross what do you
think about you're like
they should do it like in ikea like the
cafeteria style where they just give you
what does that say about me because i
knew all this and i still eat it
yeah same here i guess you know
i mean have you ever ate in asia like
it's like someone's chopping chicken and
it falls on the ground
and they taste it and they take a bite
and they're like ah good stuff
no wonder i always get sick yeah wow
bro when you start living in vegas
yeah my the best burger i've ever had in
my life yeah is at the caesars palace
in a restaurant called old homestead
it's called the old homestead burger
[ __ ] is there an egg with yolk what's
in it it's just like it
when you bite into it and it tastes like
a steak but in burgers
and there's like all this like melty
sauce and cheese on it
it's so fire we need to go to vegas just
to eat
i know okay wait i'm down for that road
trip i'm inviting myself
well how much clout do you have can you
make me work with adam how much what wow
i've
heard [ __ ] i absolutely heard cot
how much [ __ ] you have apparently none
because she wants to get pregnant but
she can't
i mean i'm so desperate no uh i i
don't know adam unfortunately i don't
know you can't come you can't come again
yeah i have faith in you like you will
you will know him soon we don't think so
too like i thought
we're all gonna work with adam yeah work
with me adam
[Music]